ihre rechnung wie können sie kanzler
werden wie viel muss die spd holen damit
das was wir sagen sie mal eine prozent
sein
ich will keine prozent sagen aber ich
sage ihnen klar es soll ein ergebnis
deutlich oberhalb von 20 prozent werden
deutlich oberhalb von 20 dann sage ich
mal 23 oder 25
ich finde alles was besonders gut ist es
immer besser als was weniger gut ist und
da ist viel drin also bleiben wir jetzt
mal bei 23 ich muss ja einmal bei 23 für
die spd wenn sie sagen oberhalb von 20
wieviel müssten dann die grünen bekommen
was glauben sie wo könnten die landen
ich weiß was ihr jetzt gerne spielen
wollen aber ich spielte dieses spiel
nicht mit weil die bürgerinnen und
bürger eine entscheidung treffen und ein
gutes mandat für die spd ist die
grundlage dafür dass es klappt
sie sagen es ist ein spiel nein ich
möchte einfach nur verstehen und unsere
zuschauer wie sie kanzler werden könnten
sagen wir mal die grünen bleiben
ungefähr dabei und die sind bei 18
vielleicht was bedeutet das dann für den
dritten partner den sie benötigen würden
also fdp oder linke was wir ihn lieber
das werden die wählerinnen und wähler
entscheiden wem sie dazu die kraft
verleihen und ist es im übrigen auch so
dass die parteien ja alle auch noch
etwas vor sich haben sie müssen ja
regierungstauglich seien zum beispiel
dafür sorgen dass wir solide finanzen
haben zum beispiel dafür sorgen dass wir
unsere aufgaben in unserem bündnis der
nato wahrnehmen können dafür sorgen dass
wir eine gut wachsende wirtschaft haben
da haben sie das stichwort natürlich
sagen sie sagen nato das könnten die
linken ja eher nicht so wenn man sich
anhört was die in den vergangenen
monaten auch wieder gesagt haben also
gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus ich gehe
mal davon aus dass es ein ordentliches
mandat geben muss für die spd damit das
funktioniert denn was ich mir wünsche
ist doch ein plebiszit also ein votum
der bürgerinnen und bürger wo sie sagen
der soll die regierung bilden
aber sie müssen sie da was wir gehört
dass mir auch die kraft verleiht dass
ich sagen kann werden regierungs
bildungs verhandlung stattfinden mit dem
oder dem das werden ja vermutlich eher
drei parteien seien sie sagen 3 und wir
wollen auch die dritten schauen also
habe ich weiß es nicht sagt die
vollkommen auf 8 vielleicht wäre das ein
ergebnis acht bis zehn wäre das ein
ergebnis mit dem sie leben können spd
bei 23
bei 18 fdp bei 8 das ist ja schon mal
ein sehr ordentliches ergebnis wenn man
das alles zusammenrechnet